[Musique]
c'est
lui
salut les terriens
somme du soir bonsoir
avec vous ce soir droite et rien ne soit
d'un robot jean mi
bon ça ils servent aujourd'hui je suis
très angoissé à l'idée de rencontrer
celui dont on ne devait pas prononcer le
nom voldemort noms reviennent
avec jean mus soir marc olivier fogiel
salut marcos a lui tiré alors dix ans
qui reçoit fogiel ce n'est pas une
émission de télé ça yalta il ya un truc
comme ça ouais c'est historique en tout
cas je suis très heureux que vous soyez
là moi je suis super content d'être là
et qui avec mon camarade maths en plus
donc
la demoiselle victoria modesto
[Applaudissements]
victoria me laisses ta bonsoir vous avez
27 ans vous êtes née en lettonie
vous êtes mannequin chanteuse
performeuse et vous êtes devenu célèbre
depuis qu'à l'âge de 20 ans après quinze
opération pour soigner votre jambe
atrophiée vous avez décidé de la faire
amputer et de la remplacer par des
prothèses créative très créative
extraordinaire beauté totale ou zurich
maintenant lady gaga a l'air
terriblement normale à côté de vous
oui sort est ce soir notre terrienne du
samedi 20 heures
et
un but encore
ça va ça va très bien on s'est pas vu
souvent dans cette émission vous n'êtes
qu'à tout et partout comme ça presque
huawei et c'est vrai que j'avais fait
tatouer pokora sur votre bras ça c'était
avant que je choisisse comme nom de
scène c'était mon premier tatouage
d'accord d'accord se faire tatouer son
nom sur le bras c'est un peu comme se
demander des autographes à soi même je
commence pour ça que je précise que je
les tatoués avantage sa tête mais
ardisson sur myspace comme
on peut le croire après le zapping et
gaspard proust nous acquérons géant
village et jean quatremer pour notre
débat s'ils visent à le droit au soir où
le grand flop je crois que gaspard à 2 -
médias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
longtemps
je voulais pas déranger je viens juste
un peu au début
pouvoir qui est qu'est-ce que je
pourrais dire de
de dégueulasse tout à l'heure
alors bon fogiel ah oui c'est maintenant
le salat j'ai vu le divan super vraiment
extraordinaire c'est vachement
apparemment le prochain client sans que
ces essais c'est vous c'est ok on vous a
déjà fait luchini c'est en une séance
vous l'avait guéri
il a 59 ans derrière la bcc là ou quoi
que votre spécialité c'est vraiment vous
trompez de vocation
et à
match et j'ai pas de blague j'ai pas de
là j'ai rien je sais pas que dire par
contre vous donc j'ai entendu votre
histoire de pied un peu particulière la
jeu j'espère que vous nous ferez une
démonstration toupie parce que c'est
non pas pour pourquoi pas
why not et j'ai entendu la filoche qui
vient tout à l'heure oui le pays n'a pas
déjà assez pleuré
non parce que j'ai rien contre lui mais
va encore venir mais est ce que vous
savez ce que c'est que vous avez vécu
c'est bah non c'est pas on n'a pas envie
on fait
là c'est wade qui parle d'argent et
comment savez vous rendez compte un
ministre du budget tu prends le risque
positif d'être visible bah non c'est
surtout la preuve que même le ministre
il trouvait que l'état demandé trop
d'impôts c'est tout bon à part ça je
reviens tout à l'heure pour le reste et
non mon staff et tout avant voix
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le robot s'appelle jean me et le groupe
y en eu 28
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on passe maintenant à notre tt ou de
la semaine
[Musique]
marc olivier fogiel re bonsoir bonsoir
tiers
et non pas re bonsoir
c'est fini tout ça vous êtes ici ce soir
pour une émission exceptionnelle marco
réalisée sous l'égide de l'onu puisque
ça y est après 15 en guerre nous sommes
réconciliés miss france avait raison la
paix dans le monde c'est possible mais
c'est bien
[Musique]
alors j'avais pensé à un lâcher de
colombes
faut dire qu'avant de nous faire la
guerre on est et on était super pote
vous avez été le seul journaliste
accepté chez moi en normandie c'était
pour un pilote pour canal+ cette chaîne
c'était la première fois que je faisais
de la télé mon cobaye et est hiriart 10
et voilà on regarde un agresseur
[Musique]
quand les gens pensent que je passe
toutes les nuits aux bains douches de 8
heures du matin et de mannequins que la
tête dans la farine tant mieux s'ils
pensent que je peux diriger deux
émissions de journaux en
endormant deux heures par nuit c'est
génial c'est un surhomme
[Musique]
si tu es obligé d'en faire de la télé tu
finis par faire la météo qu'au bout d'un
moment un jour tu te fais dire hey tu as
besoin de payer son loyer du film à
faire la météo j'ai plein d'amis à la
télé aujourd'hui qui font la musique
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
envie de passer d'être celui qui demande
aux starlettes si elles sont
clitoridiennes
vaginal ou anal
j'avais fait longtemps maintenant j'ai
envie de faire ça vous amuse plus que ça
m'amuse moi je sais maintenant
[Musique]
si j'étais pas mégalo ce serait toujours
en train de gratter pour des marchands
de lessive c'est ma mégalomanie qui m'a
sauvé
la prochaine fois manqué ma famille à la
maison
il faut beaucoup de pièces chez vous
mais c'est un grand château est une
grande famille maintenant on se fâchera
plus jamais c'est promis je rêve alors
en fait toute l'histoire avait commencé
à l'époque de de tout le monde en parle
vous aviez fait une émission qui
s'appelait on ne peut pas plaire à tout
le monde tout le monde en parle de non
ça s'appelait mon truc c'est à la même
chose
voilà donc je m'étais énervé contre vous
et j'aurais dû avoir le courage à
l'époque de m'énerver contre le le
patron de france télévisions et voilà je
m'en suis pris à vous ça a duré très
longtemps maintenant c'est fini pour
cette matière on s'aime maintenant et
maintenant mesdames messieurs un big up
pour la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors marc ollivier vu qu'on a fait la
paix maintenant vous ne serez pas étonné
que je vous fasse une interview michel
drucker
[Musique]
formidable là messieurs marc ollivier
enfin jean marc olivier fogiel ça fait
quoi d'avoir révolutionné la télévision
avec un ton nouveau ça fait chier
raidissement
sinon vous aimez les chiens marc-olivier
les rockets
lundi sylvie vartan toujours aussi ben
ouais les jours aussi jeune
alors sarkozy c'est vraiment une
politique formidable c'est lui qu'il
faut pour la france ne trouvez pas ou
pour abou dhabi aussi françois hollande
c'est vraiment un homme politique
formidable c'est lui qu'il faut pour la
france
c'est l'interview drucker la mort de
demis roussos de réponse et quoi que ça
allait faire quelques galas ou plus pour
mon copain dave
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean mi maintenant que vous avez
continué pour toujours marco tu peux
nous parler des projets d'émissions les
vendredis à 19 sur kaman sable à saper
les coûts des mafieux
il faut pas me l'énervé en a mis 15 ans
pour
une future de la serbie voilà c'est eu
la paire de manches sur terre
battue
[Musique]
vraiment soir les terrienne beaumont
soir les terriens nous sommes de retour
sur terre toujours en compagnie de
victoria
[Applaudissements]
de marc olivier fogiel
den pokora
et 2 jeanny
[Applaudissements]
marc olivier fogiel rebond soir bonsoir
quand on regarde votre vie on voit que
votre père était dentiste il avait des
clients star votre père n'en il soigné
par exemple philippe labro alors vous
aussi vous fait asseoir des stars dans
un fauteuil en or disons que tout va
bien se passer j'espère qu'il leur fait
moins mal que le dentiste peut faire mal
d'ailleurs vous vous arrachez des
confidences lui c'était des molaires
alors c'est votre père qui vous a fait
entrer rtl vous a commencé très bas au
jeu au début juillet de la trompette
sérieusement au début que des coups
pieds des flèches la nuit même avant ça
puisque j'y allais le matin avant
d'aller au lit c'est le soir en en
sortant et ensuite la nuit j'ai coupé
les dépêches puisque cela meetic ont
déjà vu mais c'était super c on
apprenait son métier là au milieu de
cette rédaction et c'était génial alors
le plus incroyable c'est qu'en préparant
cette unité à vous j'ai découvert que
nous avions énormément de points communs
ah ouais d'abord j'étais un enfant
sérieux votre soeur a dit c'était un
adulte dans un corps d'enfant oui
j'étais plutôt pas très insouciant
pendant les vacances du travail et j'ai
fait plein de petits métiers j'ai bossé
dans les bars j'étais serveurs j'étais
préparateur en pharmacie je faisais très
bien les suppôts
enfin c'est vrai il fallait couler les
suppôts
deuxième point commun nous avions tous
les deux des problèmes de surpoids et
voilà on était gros quand on était petit
mais très très gros vous avez été aux
belges qu'à l'âge de 14-15 ans était
bien bien gros dispensés de sport voilà
moi aussi troisième point commun
l'émotivité
ouais je résistais cette voie là ouais
j'avais la sueur froide j'avais les
mains moites espèce de timidité maladive
qu'on a un peu soigné à la téloche l'un
et l'autre n'ont elles sans doute le
quatrième point c'est le désir de
célébrité 1 à l'âge de 7 ans vous aviez
sur les champs elysées avec votre soeur
avec un magnétophone pour interviewer
les gens se calment incroyable ça non
mais elle sera faite faire ça en fait je
me rêvais d'être reporter moi quand je
l'aï gamin et c'est vrai que c'était un
peu en quête de notoriété il avait ce
désir moi par exemple j'avais écrit un
livre à la main et dans la préface du
j'avais 10 ans dans la préface du livre
je m'auto interview
ghana
est la dernière
célébrité s'amusèrent endives et non en
fait je me suis rendu compte assez vite
que c'est pas ça qui m'intéressait
c'était pas déplaisant bien au contraire
mais je me suis pas épanoui dans l'idée
qu'on me reconnaisse non alors on a un
autre point commun c'est qu'on est prêt
à bosser quoi mon manque de confiance en
soi ce qui fait qu'on bosse ce qui fait
qu'on n'y arrive pas finalement
[Applaudissements]
alors
dernier point
nous préférons être jugé sur une fausse
image plutôt que nous dévoiler ça c'est
vrai que c'est moi je savais un peu tu
es un peu égal qu'on puisse commenter
mon image médiatique appartement où je
me cache derrière ça me va très bien ça
sauf que maintenant avec là j'aurais
peut-être un peu de maturité je crois
l'expérience je suis plus à l'aise pour
parler plus facilement de moi comme vous
dirait
alors vous êtes ici ce soir pour nous
parler du divan votre nouvelle émission
sur france 3 alors quand vous avez
cherché un concept ou votre retour à la
télé je vais d'abord penser à ça
mais bon c'était un peu trop ensuite
vous êtes dit et si l'invité était mort
ouais absolument un et je me suis mêlé
scrive ardisson n'avait pas fait ça déjà
avant l'interview servent et s'engage
aussi pour mieux que j'évite donc j'ai
changé donc finalement vous avez choisi
le divan librement inspiré du fameux
divan d'henri chapier dont le concept
est très simple et très fort transformer
l'interview en une séance de
psychanalyse on regarde ce que tu
échappes y aiderait
venait d'avoir 40 ans vous l'avouer une
personne n'avoue jamais son âge vous
vous l'avouer parce que vous le fais pas
bien sûr mais enfin il ya vingt ans
qu'on s'obstine à vouloir prouver que
quelque part je ne sais pas peut-être
dans une autre vie vous étiez un homme
mais c'est un peu vous qui avez initié
tout ça non pourquoi dans une autre vie
oui j'ai été un homme en effet puisque
j'ai
quelqu'un en italie une fois par un
voyant un médium à m'a dit que j'avais
été un soldat je crois italien au xiiie
siècle et pillages avaient été une
esclave égyptienne très bon temps
plusieurs vies mais si on y croit dans
cette vie j'ai toujours été une femme et
j'aurais aimé être moche voilà comme ça
c'est le divan d'henri chapier et
maintenant on regarde le divan de marque
guy forget
m'a toujours amusé cette balance et
comme très souvent les gens parce que
mais je le pense vraiment que je suis
sait pas il ya des gens qui ne disent
pas moi je le dis bon je sais pas si
c'est intelligent mais j'arrive pas à
pas le dire mais on voit là mais le
problème c'est pas tellement de le dire
c'est le pensais pas je pense que je dis
évidemment elle avait su rassembler
évidemment que je pense que je dis vous
savez bien le sable boue le penser il ya
quoi de le coter faire le buzz mais il
ya aussi il n'ya pas faire le buzz je
dire j'ai pas besoin de ça pour faire le
buzz quand même ça va enfin je veux dire
mon émission marche bien je passe je
suis pas très pour faire le buzz non je
pense quoi c'est tout puis j'ai un côté
cruel c'est vrai quand j'étais petit
j'ai arraché les ailes des mouches et
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours un côté un
peu cruel
[Applaudissements]
marteau il ya un coin comme différence
alors expliquez nous ben déjà l'émission
est beaucoup plus longue l'émission
d'henri c'était une discussion débridé
pendant 26 minutes intéressantes là on
sillonne dans le parcours de vie d'un
invité de façon chapitre est celle qu'on
a fait ensemble au tir et elle fait 70
minutes et cette durée je crois permet à
l'invité de montrer peut-être plus
d'aspects de sa personnalité on
enregistrait la note qui passe
mardi il ya quelques jours quant à elle
sortie vous m'avez dit voilà la régie
sion c'est moi à oui j'ai vraiment dit
ça en tout cas vous avez été extrêmement
généreux dans ce que vous avez livré de
vous même dans les musiques en ce sens
alors
est-ce que vous n'aviez pas peur car ils
chapitre vous accuse de plagiat c'est
cette fois ci je l'avais appelé à avoir
et il m'avait donné une forme de blanc
sans danger un casting de rêve je parle
pas de moi mais il ya un hidalgo ouais
karl lagerfeld
ouais luc besson josiane balasko mêlant
chant isabelle adjani k way
dupond-moretti pas mal de voix la d2 pas
mal déjà à la forte personnalité pour
lesquelles j'ai une grande curiosité
j'aimerais beaucoup invités mate un de
ces jours ah ben oui moi tu devrais y
aller j'irai on était
bien y a un truc et c'est très difficile
la personne devant toi jeu qu'il est
derrière et s'étaient livrés à tshwane
sarpi contrairement à ce qu'ils
faisaient avant ils laissent des blancs
et laisse cette fois ci a passé déjà mis
sur le divan ça doit te faire tout drôle
de te retrouver dans le rôle du
psychanalyste et non en fait je suis pas
vraiment dangereux du psychanalyste
parce que j'ai trop de respect pour
justement le travail de thérapie moi je
me suis allongé 18 ans et là c'est
vraiment un rôle plutôt de journalistes
mais c'est vrai que le clin d'oeil
m'amuse or ici c'est vrai vous allez en
faire 20 ans ouais c'est une collection
de 20 numéros en fait voilà c'est une
espèce de parenthèse dans ma vie
professionnelle pour l'instant on verra
bien après pourquoi parce que je suis
heureux dans ce que je fais à la radio
depuis maintenant quelques années c'est
ce qui aujourd'hui occupent mais ça
prend beaucoup de temps ça va beaucoup
ou d'énergie j'ai une vie de famille que
je veux surtout pas sacrifier donc ça
laisse peu d'espacé pour faire autre
chose là j'ai trouvé des petits espaces
pour faire ça on verra après alors c'est
tous les mardis donc en deuxième partie
de soirée sur france 3 et laurent à 23h
donc voilà ça permet justement de ne pas
être au efficace et de bas chercher en
permanence qui se passe un truc toutes
les cinq secondes j'ai regardé luchini
j'ai trouvé ça bien ouais ouais pourtant
j'aime pas luchini
c'est pas vrai
m pokora rang bonsoir
c'est vu je suis très fier que jamais de
rencontrer m pokora je connais tous ses
tatouages parker
devrait dépasser chanson à bon escient
et j'en mettais au courant que si je te
fais descendre son piédestal tum arrive
aux genoux
alors maîtres chanteurs danseurs je veux
été révélée en 2003 par l'émission
popstars c'est ça et pourquoi ensuite ne
pas avoir suivi le parcours habituel des
gagnants de deux pop stars vous vouliez
pas faire serveurs
ensuite on vous a vu dans un groupe
baptisé link ap les nouvelles des deux
autres vous avez fait disparaître les
corps une bonne fois pour toutes
non un des 2 lionel avec qui je suis
resté en contact
allez toujours pattes ouais et l'autre
non non ce n'était pas très bien passée
la séparation du monde ensuite je te
lancer dans une carrière solo puis vous
remportez danse avec les stars plus vous
fait un carton avec la fameuse comédie
musicale robin des bois hier votre
fiancée la du mérite parce que elle vous
a vu avec le collant vert et tout elle
vous accordez à ger j'avais pas le
collant vert à jamais un truc un peu
plus stylé joker puis vous devenez vous
même juré de l'émission danse avec les
stars hélas la pokora magna est à son
comble aujourd'hui parce c'est une très
belle période pour moi c'est vrai que je
sors de deux projets qui ont bien marché
donc je suis sur une bonne dynamique ça
m'aide après voilà ces jeux comme je dis
je pense que moi je suis jus avant tout
ma seule prétention c'est de vouloir
divertir et faire du show du spectacle
et voilà c'est la seule chose pour
laquelle fut là les gens qui sont venus
sur les pressant de tournai visiblement
sans égal et son issue robin continuent
à venir donc pourvu que ça dure
c'est la réponse
[Musique]
alors tout va bien et là vous annoncer
que vous quittez le jury de danse avec
les stars pourquoi vous aviez peur de
venir andré manoukian
non pas du tout j'aime beaucoup andré
d'ailleurs qui appartient ce sud à
savoir deux stars peut-être non
la page alors pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
je ne peux pas reconduire cette année
c'est parce que tout simplement je suis
en tournée sinon je l'aurais fait ah
ouais comme ça vous plaît venez en train
d'essayer de trouver des solutions pour
que je puisse intervenir mais mais voilà
c'est un programme qui m'a beaucoup
apporté que j'aime beaucoup et
visiblement les téléspectateurs aussi
puisque ça marche depuis quelques années
maintenant et voilà c'est un vrai
divertissement c'est un vrai spectacle
et moi cinglé donc à l'avenir je
m'interdis pas dire tout et puis achats
le nouveau disque
l'album rouge d'un doctorat comme il y
avait l'album blanc des beatles chine
vannes
ça s'appelle red ça veut dire rite
extrêmement dangereux s'est beaucoup
bossé 1,5000 abdou 3000 points sas a
beaucoup de travail 15 tu as toi
exactement pour chaque album on regarde
aquasar fond
je ne veux plus que
[Musique]
le monde
le
on va le monde extrait de rennes
dunn pokora alors certains titres sont
signés miossec cormeilles jennifer
ayache ils ont co signé neuf quand même
pas aussi ouais bah c'est important pour
moi aussi de m'investir et de deux
voiles à deux mètres de moi et de ma
personnalité pour que je me sens le plus
à l'aise possible il ya le monde donc il
parle d'amour contrarié il ya avant nous
qui parle des anciens qui parle du
respect 1 j'ai été éduqué aussi par le
foot le sport et mon père était ancien
footballeur et mon père me disait
souvent moi quand j'arrive quand je suis
arrivée en pro à metz à l'époque
j'attendais à l'entrée du vestiaire pour
m'asseoir qu'un ancien me disent tiens
petit assainies est là aujourd'hui on
voit que les mecs ont quand même
vachement plus la confiance qu'avant et
c'est vrai que j'ai voulu faire un titre
comme ça hommage aux anciens et pour
parler de cette valeur aussi à ma
génération et c'est important de le
remettre ça sur le tapis parce que je
pense que on l'a beaucoup perdu
il ya une chanson le savez mieux que
nous qui parle du divorce vous dites que
le divorce de vos parents pour vous ça a
été un soulagement parce qu'il
n'arrêtait pas de se prendre la tête en
fait vite je les ai rarement vu
s'embrasser jamais jamais et c'est vrai
que ils ont divorcé j'avais j'avais 12
ans et en fait le déchirement pour moi
ça a été de voir mon père quitter la
maison et de me dire qu'on serait plus
jamais sous le même toit ensemble mais
c'était un soulagement parce que je ne
pouvais plus les voir prendre la tête ce
n'était pas violent mais se prendre la
tête et un stop ma mère peut
heureusement les lourdes à la maison
alors votre père lui vous amis au ballon
à l'âge de 6 ans vous mettiez des
crampons pour jouer dans le jardin
vouloir ni qui est jamais exactement
c'était un peu c'était un peu le
problème c'est pour ça que j'ai pas trop
le droit de jouer mais mais ouais j'ai
commencé très tôt pas forcément avec un
papa m
ensuite cette année c'est à sedan à 15
ans je suis mal passée s'est pas très
bien passé d'une gt
bêtement partir en vacances pendant deux
semaines juste avant l'essai je me suis
pas entraîné donc je suis arrivé j'étais
à la rue main et puis j'ai pas forcément
jouer mon poste voilà j'ai pas été
retenu et et en rentrant à strasbourg
j'ai voulu arrêter et du coup c'est pour
ça qu'après je veux j'ai commencé
vraiment à mettre dans la main après il
ya une pop star c'est ça deux ans après
dès aujourd'hui vous êtes une star la
preuve de la pub pour des lunettes alors
que vous ne portez jamais maintenant
c'est fini madrid la bad en bois
c'est vrai et regardez m pokora la
plupart du temps
absurdes opéré à ce que je me suis
vraiment fait pendant robin des bois
donc j'en sais un peu moi comme si je
faisais de la pub pour des slips alors
que
la canne de suite amicaux n'ont cédé que
c'est un montage
y'a pas de slip mpokora non il faudra en
faire moi j'en mettrais la mèche à mèche
y avait des slips m pokora tuer mais je
les bombes h m
[Applaudissements]
qui
s'est plutôt claude françois johnny
hallyday mais elle est bien la chanson
ouais c'est vrai que même jeu j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour ce que claude
françois a fait c'est vrai que voilà
c'est un des premiers à avoir amené
cette culture aussi
américaine du show et du divertissement
en france et c'est vrai que voilà moi
mes influences sont plus vous êtes comme
ça je pense d'alternateur tiner
exactement comme lui moi c'est mon truc
si divertissement faire jean chaude
voilà c'est ça oui j'ai envie de vous
dire quelque chose mais si papa tu as
dit que tu voulais être lé nouveau
claude françois
je peux être étape correcte
si ses dents serrées grand plaisir elle
sait danser c'est vrai il a dansé ici
avec son jumeau jean py et les danseurs
de beyoncé ah ouais mais c'est arrivé au
club avec grand plaisir
tu as trouvé du boulot
et maintenant on va faire une interview
brûlons l'idole
là je vais essayer de vous détruire
devant votre public c'est rouge est ce
que vous fumez non je suis pas bon vous
buvez
valait quatre fois par an ah ouais ça va
être dus à la est-ce que vous avez déjà
dit à une femme tu sais tu as de la
chance d'être avec moi
il m'est arrivé quand je présidais n'est
pas parce que c'était moi parce que je
venais je venais d'apporter une petit
déjeuner est d'accord voilà est-ce que
vous conduisez bourg et parfois alors je
suis très rarement bourg est en général
si si si je si je prends un peu d'alcool
pour m'amuser je j'ai quelqu'un qui me
ramène ça va être dur de bonnet rigole
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille je t'aime plus que tout au monde
juste pour arriver à la sotech tu
sais c'est quand même plus facile avec
notre métier on n'a pas besoin de ça et
vous thierry
non
preixan
métissage me mary
est-ce que vous avez déjà torturer un
animal
ouais
quand même
jeu
ouais ouais bah comme toi les mouches ça
m'est déjà arrivé ouais et puis les
guêpes découpé comme ça
voilà sur chaque rayures de la bei
vous avez déjà séduit la femme d'un pote
nom
d'une connaissance peut-être mais d'un
pote
d'accord
vu de jarry à une blague raciste
bah oui
vous donner des notes aux filles avec
lesquelles vous coucher
non non
l'uriné
attendait j'avais déjà eu une expérience
homosexuelle à plusieurs jamais
c'est chiant elle est chiante ma vie
j'en fais trop tard maintenant jette
pour la peine de mort
il y en a ils mériteraient vous avez
déjà giflé un enfant comme françois
bayroux
mais il est pape et à son portable ou un
truc à eux
n'ont jamais giflé un enfant j'ai déjà
touché aux drogues très très dur non ça
me fait peur mais il est parfait ce gars
voilà c'était la paix jeu de france 3
après la pub avec le débat le jumping
aux stars bush et matériel jusqu'à 20h
ce soir victoria modèle star attitude
[Musique]
hors amont soit luthérienne au rebond
soir les terriens nous sommes de retour
sur terre toujours en compagnie de
victoria modeste
de marc olivier fogiel
même temps
et 2 janvier
[Applaudissements]
alors victoria modesta bossoirs vous
êtes chanteuse danseuse performeuse vous
êtes celle que la presse britannique a
surnommée la popstar bionique amputé de
la jambe gauche à l'âge de 20 ans vous
êtes l'héroïne d'un clip hallucinant
dans lequel vous exposer des prothèses
toutes plus spectaculaires les unes que
les autres sur internet le clip a été vu
dix millions de fois en une semaine on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
vous nous raconterez autre histoire à 20
heures jean-mi celle où je suis heureux
que nous recevions une amie et moi venez
à toi je connais assez bien ses jambes
on a été fabriqué ensemble
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant au delà de la
semaine avec l'éditeur de blacko et
c'est gérard filoche membre du bureau
national du ps et jean quatremer
journaliste à libération que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto ce soir nous poserons la
question syriza grands soirs où grand
flop
[Musique]
pour que la france suive les grecs
faudrait que mélenchon se retrouve à
matignon après tout pourquoi pas si la
crise s'aggravait encore des millions de
français descendus dans les rues du
crawl en serait obligé de dissoudre
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale au législatives mélenchon
arrivé en tête sauf que pour avoir la
majorité il lui faudrait s'allier à la
droite souverainiste et c'est comme ça
que dupont aignan boutin et guaino se
retrouverait dans son gouvernement ça
vous paraît crédible en tout cas dupont
aignan est dans les starting blocks déjà
il est super content de la victoire de
la gauche radicale est heureux de la
victoire d'alexis ça paraît paradoxal de
six choix heureux de la victoire de d'un
parti qui est oui à gauche gauche
radicale a dit call et surtout il est
prêt à s'allier avec mélenchon vous
pourriez passer un accord avec le front
de gauche de mélenchon si c'est pour
sauver la france eux est fixée sur un
programme intelligent de création de
richesses pourquoi pas comme quoi la
victoire de syriza s'est pas seulement
la victoire de la gauche radicale c'est
aussi celle de tous les adversaires du
système politique européen la preuve
quand même marine le pen s'est félicitée
de la victoire de syriza je me réjouis
de la gifle démocratique monstrueuse que
le peuple grec vient d'administrer à
l'union européenne en grèce
le clivage droite gauche ça ne veut plus
rien dire puisque la gauche radicale se
retrouve dans le même camp que la droite
nationaliste désormais il ya deux camps
ceux qui défendent le système sollicite
européens et ceux qui le combattent les
anti système font de plus en plus
nombreux aussi bien à gauche qu'à droite
ça prouve que clivage gauche droite est
totalement inopérant notamment sur les
enjeux européens avec le pliage et
ailleurs est entre patriotes
souverainiste et ceux qui sont consommés
à l'union européenne et 0 kaka alors
est-ce qu'un scénario à la grecque
pourrait se produire en france pourquoi
pas sauf que chez nous si un parti anti
système devait succéder au ps et à l'ump
ben le fn paraît mieux placé que les
enfants dupont aignan cela dit même
quand un peuple vote contre l'austérité
à l'europe ce n'est pas si facile d'y
échapper la preuve il a suffi que la
banque centrale européenne décide de ne
plus financer les banques grecques pour
que la grèce risque à nouveau la
cessation de paiement d'ici fin février
alors syriza a beau avoir le soutien de
son peuple à moins de sombrer dans la
faillite la grèce aura du mal à échapper
à ses créanciers voilà c'était délicat
de blacko nous en images de julia
grappes
josh bon soir il est membre du bureau
national du ps votre livre comment
résister à la démolition du code du
travail est toujours en librairie et
vous publierez en mars vive l'entreprise
bribes de vie et de mort au travail chez
hugo et compagnie bienvenue parmi nous
et un
jean quatremer bonsoir
journaliste à libération notamment
spécialiste des questions européennes
bienvenue parmi nous alors les 25
janvier a eu lieu en grèce des élections
législatives anticipées pour élire un
nouveau gouvernement
et d'après ce qu'on a pu voir sur les
chaînes de télévision françaises
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a gagné les
élections
alexis tsipras ce et son ministre des
finances yannis varoufakis on entame une
tournée européenne il en a appris jeudi
matin que la bce la banque centrale
européenne coupe le robinet aux banques
grecques ne conservant qu'une ligne de
crédit d'urgence alors gérard c'est la
fin de la récré là adieu le grand soir
annoncé le début avant d'abord
démocratie si vous permettez c'est le
peuple qui a voté ouais on peut pas une
bande va pas aller contre le pape non
direz vous c'est la banque si la bce
leur couplet laisser le pop qui dirigent
ou c'est la banque ouais bon c'est une
victoire pour les grecs syriza c'est la
gauche unie ça serait du bien en france
il ça arrivait et puis en même temps
c'est la bataille contre l'austérité ils
disent stop à tous les bureaucrates de
la banque centrale européenne qui
veulent l'essayer ça fait du bien il
rappela bas et ça nous ferait du bien de
les soutenir là bas parce qu'ils nous
aident ici on fait quoi maintenant parce
que la dette grecque et les craintes de
321 milliards d'euros 170 7 % du pib il
reste 2 milliards dans les caisses et
fin février défaut de paiement
c'est-à-dire comment la grèce va-t-elle
payer ses fonctionnaires fin février si
la bce ne file pas un peu tout d'abord
grâce aux différents programmes
d'austérité aujourd'hui lesquels le
budget grec et à l' équilibre c'est à
dire que les grecs ils peuvent vivre
avec ce qu'ils ont donc imaginons que
demain ils fassent défaut c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne refusent de rembourser la
dette qui est détenu je le rappelle par
l'ensemble des états européens y compris
les pays baltes qui ont prêté de
l'argent à la grèce pour l'aider à s'en
sortir des pays beaucoup plus pauvre que
la grèce a comme la slovaquie les trois
pays baltes la slovénie etc et peuvent
faire défaut et ils peuvent très bien
continuer à vivre comme ça le seul
problème il peut rester dans l'euro ça
veut pas dire qu'il sort de l'euro
simplement personne ne prêtera plus
d'argent donc il n'est pas question
qu'ils aillent à emprunter sur les
marchés il n'est pas question qu'il
vienne de nouveau demandé aux européens
ou effet mis de les aider en france par
exemple si jamais la grèce ne rembourse
pas sa dette on a prêté aux grecs 41
milliards d'euros ça fait 6 131 euros
par francis franck ribéry fait 500 ce
qui fait mouche
et traiter chaque fois là c'est ce que
vous avez prétendu bien qu'alors ci
devront décider si demain lui vient ce
chimie vient ce chiffre il vient tout
simplement il viendra goût de ce chiffre
il vient tout simplement des prêts
bilatéraux qu'on a fait à la grèce qui a
garanti qu on a donné aux mécanisée ça
n'a jamais rien reçu elle est restée des
prêts aux créanciers de la grèce c'est à
dire aux banques et ce sont les banques
privées qui sont responsables de tout ça
parce que la banque centrale européenne
elle prêtait 1000 milliards aux banques
privées à 1% donc les banques privées
prêter aux grecs à 10 % donc c'est
l'envol le vol de la grèce il vient des
banques privées et celles et tous ceux
dont tu parles c'est de rembourser les
banques privées et tu crois que tu
devenais ce nous français nous
rembourser les banques privées maison
les quatre banques françaises aux 8000
milliards à qu'ils s'y sont pas corrigés
le continent chantage pur et d'y aller
je peux parler oui
on va résumer la crise selon gérard
filoche ce sont des méchantes banques et
la méchante union européenne qui sont
arrivés en grèce qui ont obligé les
grecs empruntés plein d'argent qui les
ont poussés à se ruiner et qui du jour
au lendemain et ensuite ils ont coûté à
l'austérité non mais je veux dire que
c'est quand même confessé le 10 décembre
c'est le disneyland de l'économie que tu
es en train de dresser sur ce bateau la
fraude fiscale en grèce représente entre
20 et 40 milliards d'euros par an si les
grecs avaient payé leurs impôts comme
tout le monde n'aurait même pas eu
besoin d'emprunter il sait pas de trêve
il admire la barre et puis depuis deux
mois il ya 2 milliards d'euros d'impôts
qui ne sont pas rentrées dans les
caisses pourquoi parce que les grecs ont
arrêté de payer les impôts en disant
qu'ils allaient avoir une amnestie vous
savez vous rappeler comme du temps des
contraventions on arrêtait de les payer
11 ans à bassam élections
présidentielles exactement pourquoi
c'est lé peuple grec qui est accusé lors
qu'il n'avait pas vu le grec était
dirigé par des gens corrompus ils
viennent d'être battus les dogues
n'auront pu vivre syriza parce que là
c'est l'espoir d'avoir une nouvelle est
sûre il faudra toute l'europe
applaudissent éméché risa ils sont à
lire qu'un parti qui s'appelle anne elle
qui est xénophobe homophobe mais c'est
un accord quand ils rentrent ici un
accord technique n'est pas d'accord il
faut dire ce que vous dites là c'est
qu'en france on peut s'associer que le
front national en disant non c'est un
accord technique d'abord ses potes front
national selon lui les fans rage et la
passer au blu ray mais deuxièmement
c'est un accord technique il avait 149
députés il a besoin de deux députés pour
faire leur politique sinon vous pouvez
rien faire donc ils ont passé un accord
avec lui quoi vous vous associez le à
moi moi je suis à la place de type rage
au fait ça tout de suite vous
remarquerez quand même la morale
extrêmement élastique du de gérard
filoche un angle du reér plastique dans
trois citernes ont extrêmement surpris
parce qu'on puisse justifier offrant pas
une alliance qui est totalement contre
nature ils pouvaient très bien un petit
prince pouvait très bien s'allier avec
ton pote ami qui s'appelle un petit
parti s'appelle la rivière mais qui en
raison d'un petit problème de madame là
c'est un petit problème c'est qu'il est
illusoire opère dans les deux sens au
grain avec lui mais on préfère on
préfère donc s'allier avec un parti qui
est vraiment une frange du parc du front
national et une frange dure du front
national ils sont pas fasciste ça c'est
vrai ils sont démocrates mais pour tout
le reste c'est vraiment le côté ceux en
de l'extrême droite et que monsieur
filoche viennent justifier ici à la télé
française une alliance est un tueur là
moi ça me disais ça montre ça montre que
la gauche la gauche de la gauche
française n'a pas beaucoup de morale je
vais vous dire quelque chose dont se
mange et de la morale n'hésite pas une
seule seconde avalisé ce que fait syriza
et je trouve curieux mais là rien c'est
pour l'instant je trouve curieux et
l'arrière frais au contraire il a fait
en deux jours qui va et françois
hollande hélas n'a pas fait en deux ans
aucune voilà des mois qu'il a fait toute
une série de mesures tout à fait
positive bien je m'excuse et ces mesures
positives que je défends ça t'intéresse
temps qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord tous les deux on est dans la
merde
c'était le mot de la fin
[Applaudissements]
dans un instant gaspard pouces mais
d'abord le zapping c'était le zapping et
maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
port elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
rester fit alors je suis resté pour toi
quel courage
non je suis un peu il faut que je revoie
parce que j'avais un coup de fil à de
sofinco là tu fais ce que j'ai à crédit
et
je leur ai dit non mais moi je rembourse
pas enfin je suis contre l'austérité
donc ça va prend à priori ça c'est bon
puisque
voilà alors actualité alors nice encore
une attaque terroriste un loup blanc
enfin je trouve ça plutôt un fennec je
ne sais pas ça dégoûtant quand tu penses
que ça aurait pu être évité si seulement
avant de faire sa connerie lemay qui
s'étaient connectés au site stop
djihadisme
donc à nice 3 militaires se font
agresser à l'armé blanche alors je vous
rassure à l'agresseur n'a rien
alors tu vas me dire il était armé
pourquoi ils n'ont pas tiré il faut
savoir que cette année il y aura eu un
problème avec les flingues aux dernières
nouvelles jouéclub résolu le problème
non c'est vrai c'est presque ça sent
l'ail et donc
après faut comprendre un coulibaly parce
que l'agresseur s'appelle couliboeuf
il y avait une chance sur un million
c'est sur nous
le mec de l'hyper cacher il aura
vraiment tout raté quoi mourir dans un
magasin alors qu'il avait le sens de la
franchise
bref les soldats ont été décorés parce
qu'ils ont réussi à maîtriser le mec
sans faire usage de leurs armes
ouais
les mecs qui passent leurs journées à se
faire chier à ce problème des fusils qui
pèse 5 kg et on les décors parce qu'ils
arrivent à s'en servir comme matraque
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude on a décortiqué le
profil de l'agresseur et c'est toujours
le même profil une fois de plus il est
poli il est gentil
il est allé coûte c'est quand même
dingue c'est bien mais qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour coller la dcr -aucune
drucker
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours nouvelle élection
partielle fn contre ps au 2e tour
première victime c'est nicolas s'est
alors maintenant ça tombe sur vie cécile
coulibaly de la politique
sarkozy outragé sarko s'y briser sarkozy
martyrisé mais sarkozy conférencier
le mec qui se fait humilier en 2012 en
se faisant battre par hollande et l'a
humilié par ses propres lieutenants non
mais non mais non c est ce qu on se rend
compte est-ce qu'on se rend compte le
mec qui se fait contesté par nkm voky
juppé ciotti châtel qui est le chef qui
le chef moi moi moi j'ai l'impression de
voir mot histoire devant la mer rouge et
les mecs autour qui lui disent non c'est
des conneries ton l'idée d'ouvrir la mer
la salle je crois pas non moi je connais
une digue départementale qui passe par
un col super sympa et un autre qui
arrive non mais n'importe quoi si tu
prends un peu sur la gauche par santi tu
tombes sur une autoroute direct sur le
sida et et nicolas qui s'énerve et plus
tard c'est moi le chef moi je vais
ouvrir la mer quand j'ai non mais calmes
toi arrête tes conneries pose ton bâton
tu vas te faire mal
à deux ans de l'échéance il a perdu
c'est un génie il réussi à perdre
stalingrad avant que la guerre ait
commencé
mais je crois qu'il faut intervenir et
quand il faut intervenir et à spin
proust série spin doctor que j'ai
inventé
je change de rôle voilà
bon nicolas mois moi je sais ce qui se
passe en ce moment en toi je le sens pas
de geste brusque je respecte ta colère
tu sais depuis ton retour bibi il avait
senti qu'il y avait un décalage entre ce
que tu racontes est ce que tu sens ça se
voit tout de suite que la synthèse c'est
pas ton truc même ton corps il n'est pas
prévu pour ça donc que ton corps il est
dit l'aînée prévu pour découper ddd
petite bavette d'aloyau mais pas pour
malaxer de la pâte à crêpes tu vois tu
es un mec t'es tu étais comme ça quoi
t'es pas fait pour ça et est ce que je
sens très fort en toi mais très fort
c'est que au fond de toi tu as besoin de
meurtre mais il faut le faire
concrètement et de manière légale parce
que débarqué avec une kalach au conseil
de l'ump c'est quoi sinon impossible à
réaliser
moi
moi je le deviens td il faut y aller un
parent en choisissant ses cibles morano
c'est pas compliqué et nadim c'est moral
ou tu t'en débarrasser facile tu prends
une grenade tu l'achète et je me dis vas
chercher de
javier bertrand xavier bertrand faut y
aller au vice à la subtilité tous les
jours tu fais livrer cinq kilos de
chouquettes pur beurre fourré ont
intérêt au saindoux un a priori dans un
mois c'est bison futé dans ses artères
c'est bon
bruno le maire c'est le mec poser est où
tu sens que c'est un coin c'est qui est
fasciné par les lumières faut le
bombarder d'invités je te paraît qu'en
moins trois mois on va le retrouver au
carlton de lille à s'enfiler delachoux
venue avec trois lolita seloncourt
[Applaudissements]
alors tu vas me dire et jupe etc et que
je fais de juppé juppé je te dis tout de
suite il faut pas le ménager il faut le
déménager
il aura 72 ans en 2017 je te dis ça je
t'ai rien dit tu fais juste un truc à
l'ump tu baisses le thermostat il est
avant tu m'as 19 le mec qui s'enrhume
c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
alors le pauvre comme si ça ne suffisait
pas au même moment valls est passé
devant lui dans les sondages 2e tour
présidentiel ce qui m'a inspiré un petit
poème poème
le soir tombait la législative partielle
était bien noir il avait pourtant
l'offensive et presque la victoire il
tenait françois acculé sur son pédalo
malgré ses tics et ses conférences sur
le dos il supporter paisiblement le
temps long d'avant 2017 faisant dans la
synthèse improbable attriste saynètes
languissant d'être coincé entre deux
amants que tout oppose la gauche au
point le fn à la rose il guettait les
sondages qui lui donnerait des ailes
aveugle et d'espoir il s'écrie un
nicolas c'était manuel voir
pour finir
sur une note positive enfin
encourageante des chats brûlé le pilote
jordanien c'est encourageant bah oui on
progresse avant et décapité maintenant
ils viennent de découvrir le feu
on passe du cru au cuit
moi je suis sûr que d'ici quelques
millions d'années ils feront de très
jolis peintures rupestres
alors à la vie
bush
on passe maintenant à notre matériel du
samedi 20 heures
la fin
victoria me des stars bonsoir
vous êtes chanteuse danseuse performeuse
vous êtes celle que la presse
britannique a surnommée la popstar
bionique amputé de la jambe gauche à
l'âge de 20 ans vous êtes l'héroïne d'un
clip hallucinant dans lequel vous
exposer des prothèses toutes plus
spectaculaires les unes que les autres
sur internet le clip a été vu dix
millions de fois en une semaine et on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
alors victoria
bon jeu par thierry vous êtes né le 25
février 1987 sous le nom de victoria
mosca lova à daugavpils en lettonie
votre père travaille dans la marine et
votre mère est coiffeuse l'accouchement
se passe mal les médecins vous démettre
la jambe gauche et la hanche
les jours suivants les médecins tentent
de réparer les dégâts provoqués par leur
incompétence
hélas ils ne font qu'aggraver les choses
ils plâtre la jambe alors que vous
n'avez que deux semaines mauvais médecin
oui c'est vrai bien sûr le plâtre stop
la croissance de la jambe et en
grandissant la déformation s'accentue et
devient une véritable infirmité entre 6
et 12 ans vous subissez 15 opérations
mais les résultats sont décevants c'est
dû être terrible cet enfant se
vous êtes un enfant
ne comprenait pas forcément ce à quoi
devrait ressembler votre vie vous êtes
dans un environnement et puis vous
essayez finalement d'avancer dans la vie
alors évidemment en grandissant les
problèmes de mobilité s'aggrave pouvait
pas porter ta l'on pouvait pas porter de
jupe ou pouvait pas faire de sport ça
vous pose aussi des problèmes dans vos
études parce que vous êtes à l'hôpital
et quand vous êtes à l'hôpital vous
n'êtes pas l'école donc tout ce que vous
savez vous l'avez appris par vous même
vous êtes une autodidacte
j'ai tout simplement suivi ce qui
m'intéressait ce qui me passionne et
je pense que ça a été la meilleure forme
d'éducation possible j'ai appris tout ce
que je voulais j'ai pu m'en seigneur ce
que je souhaitais à prendre et ça a été
très utile pour moi est bien vrai mme de
l'urss
à quel lettonie appartient encore à
l'époque les médecins conseils à vos
parents de vous éloigner de vous mettre
dans un orphelinat à l'abri des regards
et heureusement votre mère n'est pas du
tout d'accord
j'ai eu énormément chance moi même j'ai
grandi en lettonie
et je sentais fortement cette influence
la communauté post soviétique était très
négative à l'égard des personnes qui
étaient différentes physiquement
différent et à travers l'amour que me
porter ma mère
et bien je ne voulais pas que c'était la
situation pourquoi aurais-je dû accepter
que qui que ce soit me dise que j'étais
moins que quiconque d'autre heureusement
il ya la musique le piano le solfège en
1999 après une quinzaine d'opérations
pour trouver les meilleurs chirurgiens
vos parents décident de quitter la
lettonie pour s'installer à l'ombre donc
vous arrivez à londres mais là au lycée
vous êtes mal traités et le pire de tout
en fait c'est que les professeurs ferme
les yeux
je me suis dit que les gens sont
négatifs à votre regard car ils ont peur
de quelque chose parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas quelque chose
donc finalement c'était pas mon problème
c'était le leur bravo quitté l'école à
14 ans et à ce moment là vous intéresser
beaucoup à la mode vous posé pour des
magazines vous fréquenter des clubs
fétichiste vous devenez tour à tour
gothique
burlesque cyberpunk
mais votre jambe continue à vous poser
des problèmes et c'est là qu'ils ont
décidé
victoria de vous faire amputer vous
allez voir un chirurgien luzenac tj
cette jambe je voudrais qu'on me
l'enlève
le premier chirurgien ne comprends pas
à ce moment là vous allez voir des
spécialistes de fabrication de prothèses
pour monter un dossier
de façon à ce que les chirurgiens ne
puisse pas vous refuser l'amputation
faudra cinq ans pour les convaincre et
aussitôt après l'opération
quand vous enlevez les couvertures vous
êtes soulagé et vous dites
c'était comme si c'était noël
c'était c'était un peu la morphine quand
même
peut-être bien peut-être bien mais
je pense que l'on donne beaucoup trop de
valeur au corps humain
donc pour moi ça a été un véritable
soulagement sont là c'est
parce que j'ai été en mesure de laisser
tout cela derrière moi alors désormais à
partir de là vous pouvez entamer votre
marche vers la star itude et votre
amputation va devenir votre force en
2012 vous chantez la cérémonie de
clôture des jeux paralympiques de
londres
vous incarnez la reine des neiges sur
une musique de coldplay et en décembre
2014 en collaboration avec la chaîne de
télévision channel fort vous présenter
la vidéo prototype
la prothèse en forme de pique noir vous
l'avez rêvé en fait cette prothèse
réfléchir une silhouette intéressante
qui sera approprié à mon corps
j'ai la liberté pouvoir changer de
modifier la silhouette de mon corps et
donc je pense que c'était quelque chose
de très intéressant envisagé
dans ce qui vous parle également de
votre sexualité on peut vous voir faire
l'amour sans prothèse vous en parlé très
librement vous trouvez qu'on n'ose pas
parler en fait de la sexualité des gens
handicapés vous vous en parlait
en fait il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'objectivité lorsque
non regarde des individus et on décore
différence on a tendance à les traiter
comme si c'est des personnes dépourvues
d'identité sexuelle ce qui est
extraordinaire avec vous victoria sait
que le handicap départ c'était de la
honte c'était dur j'ai ensuite la
société a essayé de faire accepter les
handicapés et on y arrive mais ce qui
est génial avec vous c'est que le
handicap c'est une fierté
le défi le plus grand auquel je suis
confronté à l'heure actuelle
est bien c'est de faire en sorte que
nous n'utilisions plus ce terme
handicapé je pense qu'il n'est
absolument plus approprié dans ces temps
modernes
quelqu'un assis à côté de moi qui peut
être est complètement sain de corps
et qui ne contribuent absolument pas à
la société qui peut-être ne vit pas une
saillie qu'il ne fait rien et bien je
pense qu'il est bien plus handicapé que
quelqu'un qui a amputé d'une jambe
alors pour conclure une classe devront
que j'adore plus tu vivras ta vie comme
un film plus elle sera excitante génial
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
but samedi avec jean mi avec victoria me
destin avec marc olivier fogiel
avec un pokora gérard filoche jean
quatremer
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission salut le cas
coupez et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu